t chez les forces de l'ordre ce qui
n'est bon pour personne ni pour la
population ni pour la police elle même
au delà d'être dangereux inutiles c'est
dommageable à ce que vous défendez pour
permettre aux forces de l'ordre exercer
leurs missions dans de meilleures
conditions
en effet si vous vous en étiez tenue au
titre ou un sur l'élargissement du
domaine d'action des polices municipales
et au titre 2 sur un meilleur
encadrement de l'exercice de la
profession d'agent de sécurité
notre groupe liberté et territoire
auraient voté pour ce texte
oui la mise en adéquation de la conduite
de la politique de sécurité avec des
caractéristiques des territoires par
l'expérimentation de l'élargissement des
moyens d'action des polices municipales
et bienvenus cela vient compléter des
missions sur lesquels les agents n'ont
pas toute latitude pour mener à bien la
lutte contre l'insécurité des causes du
quotidien qui leur est dévolue et cela
également au niveau intercommunal mais
mes chers collègues
il est des éléments sur lequel notre
groupe ne peut accepter
il s'agit de la défense des libertés
fondamentales
pourtant nous avons fait des
propositions pour mieux encadrer les
dispositions que vous nous proposez dans
le but qu'elle soit véritablement utile
aux agents et à la population
nous n'avons pas été entendus que cela
soit par caméra piétons ou drones les
logiciels de traitement de
reconnaissance faciale doivent être
clairement interdite a fortiori lors des
manifestations sur la voie publique qui
verrait un grand nombre d'individus
identifiés et augurerait de l'ouverture
d'une société de surveillance de masse
de manière incompréhensible
vous avez rejeté notre amendement tout
aussi incompréhensible
vous avez avoué lors des débats que les
dispositions de cette loi concernant le
respect de la vie privée des individus
filmé par drones notamment
l'interdiction de filmer l'intérieur de
leur domicile ne pourra pas se tenir
matériellement vous nous demandez donc
de voter une loi dont vous savez
pertinemment qu'elle sera inapplicable
et qu'elle portera atteinte à la vie
privée des citoyens
par ailleurs ces images filmées par les
forces de l'ordre ne peuvent avoir pour
finalité d'être un outil de com
nication leur disposition en vue
d'établir une vérité dans une
intervention caractérisée par des
comportements potentiellement
répressibles de part et d'autre
premièrement vous avez refusé de revenir
sur le fait que les agents puissent
avoir directement accès à leur propre
image au risque de peser un soupçon sur
leur probité
deuxièmement il convient que la
diffusion de ces images d'intervention
puisse se faire au regard des critères
de transparence et d'objectivité par une
autorité indépendante renforcée mais
vous avez aussi refusé cette proposition
ce n'est pourtant pas le rôle de la
police que d'entrer dans une guerre des
images avec ses propres citoyens
enfin nous soutenons qu'il est
parfaitement insupportable que des
jantes police ou de gendarmerie puisse
subir des harcèlements ou des menaces de
mort parfois mise à exécution
mais ce que vous proposez à l'article 24
même dans la nouvelle rédaction du
gouvernement qui n'est à notre sens que
la communication se révélera
parfaitement inefficients pour protéger
les forces de l'ordre et véritable ans
de jeu dangereux pour nos libertés
fondamentales
cela posera des problèmes
constitutionnels multiples comme l'a
énoncé la défenseur des droits
l'imprécision de votre rédaction et du
caractère d'intentionnalité de porter
atteinte aux agents fera que la
diffusion des vidéos exposants des cas
pratiques illégales par la police soit
rendue extrêmement difficile alors que
le droit de filmer la police relève de
la liberté d'expression et du droit de
la formation la diffusion serait
drastiquement découragés par le risque
juridique encouru qui impliquerait de
censurer des contenus pour s'éviter des
poursuites
pourtant ce que vous visez et déjà
réprimer et cela encore plus fortement
par l'article 433 3 du code pénal vous
n'avez pas su démontrer que notre
arsenal juridique est insuffisant aussi
mes chers collègues je termine monsieur
le président
parmi les mesures contenues dans ce
texte que nous trouvons nom et
l'équilibré non proportionnée quant au
respect des libertés fondamentales une
grande majorité la majorité de notre
vous de votre à contres merci monsieur
mot la hague la parole à monsieur le
président jean luc mélenchon pour cinq
minutes pour le groupe la france
insoumise
résident collègues ministres alerte
alerte après vingt-deux loi soit disant
sur la sécurité sans que personne n'en
n'ai jamais fait le bilan
en trente ans à présent vous en rajoutez
trois en l'espace de trois ans cette loi
en l'espace de trois ans et le but est
maintenant assez clair en régimes
autoritaires se met en place dans le but
est de contrôler tout le monde tout le
temps partout sans aucune restriction à
ce droit de se mêler de la vie de chacun
à tout instant d'une loi d'initiative
parlementaire
vous avez tiré le moyen de faire une
cage électronique dans laquelle vous
voyez enfermer la france une cage dans
laquelle en permanence par les caméras
piétons les drones la reconnaissance
faciale
l'interconnexion des caméras de vidéo
surveillance privée dans les parkings et
les halls d'immeuble s'ajoute une
interdiction de plus l'interdiction de
regarder c'est à dire l'interdiction de
filmer pour permettre qu'on voit la
dangerosité d'une telle disposition
vous en avez rendu compte vous même
monsieur le ministre ce matin car vous
avez dit les images que j'ai vues cette
nuit mot choqué c'est pourquoi je
demande un rapport de l'inspection
générale de la police nationale
donc vous voyez les images sont très
utiles pour réprimer les abus de pouvoir
et vous voyez que la première des
libertés dans le citoyen à jouir c'est
celle de pouvoir contrôler ceux qui
exercent l'autorité reculer monsieur le
ministre
arrêter tout ça a quel abîme roule la
france de cette manière d'autres
présidents d'autres gouvernements avant
vous ont reculé qui pourtant se sentent
est sûrs de leur bon droit
le président françois mitterrand à
propos de la loi sur l'école privée le
président jacques chirac à quatre
reprises et notamment sur la réforme des
retraites qui lui tenait à coeur en 1995
le président françois hollande lorsqu'il
a voulu faire adopter la déchéance de
nationalité
il n'y a pas de honte à reculer
lorsqu'on s'aperçoit que la voie dans
laquelle on s'est engagés nuit à la
patrick et à l'idée qu'on se fait de la
république
la répression des gilets jaunes avaient
déjà été condamnés par le haut
commissaire aux droits de l'homme de
l'onu dont on a parlé tout à l'heure par
le conseil de l'europe par le parlement
européen
plusieurs institutions internationales
auxquelles vous vous référez si souvent
se sont exprimés sur cette loi
le 16 novembre le conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu parle d'atteinte
importante aux droits de l'homme et aux
libertés fondamentales en france le 23
novembre c'est la commission européenne
dont vous vous réclamez tout le temps
qu'ils disent que les états membres
doivent respecter le principe de
proportionnalité et trouver le juste
équilibre entre la garantie de sécurité
publique et la protection des droits et
elle ajoute cette commission européenne
qu'elle se réserve le droit d'examiner
la législation finale afin de vérifier
sa conformité avec le droit de l'union
européenne
vous allez bientôt pouvoir faire un club
avec monsieur or ban avec le président
de la hongrie avec celui de la pologne
montrée du doigt par toute l'europe
démocratique comme étant des apprentis
tyran qui dirigent des régimes
autoritaires
j'ajoute enfin que ce samedi et au fil
des navettes qui vont offert le passage
de cette loi du sénat à l'assemblée et
vice versa renoncer à la violence
renoncer aux systèmes du nas âge qui
donne eu à chaque fois du débordement
incroyable de violences dans le pays et
dans les rues reprenez le tour
tranquille des gardiens de la paix il
est temps qu'il y ait une reprise en
main de la police républicaine parce que
quand vous ne tenez pas vous ne tenait
plus que par elle et elle vous tient
elle vous tiens c'est elle qui vous
dicte ce qu'il faudrait faire
et de qui parle-t-on de deux syndicats
de factieux qui n'hésite pas une seule
fois insulté les parlementaires à
menacer assiégé les sièges et même les
sièges de télévision
le moment venu après ces manifestations
si le peuple francs
c'est le veut nous appliquerons une
stratégie de désescalade entre la police
et les citoyens nous interdirons les
grenades et les ailes bd dans les
manifestations nous supprimerons
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale qui est spécialisé dans l'art
de regarder ailleurs pour la remplacer
comme en grande bretagne par une
institution indépendante pour la
déontologie de la police comme c'est le
cas au royaume uni nous abrogerons cette
loi nous introduirons nous retirerons du
droit commun les lois d'exception que
vous y avez misé et enfin nous
rétablirons le code de déontologie qui
avait imposé à la police nationale le
grand ministre pierre joxe qui avait mis
au premier rang le respect des droits de
l'homme et de la république que vous en
avez retiré
merci monsieur le président à paroles
est à monsieur stéphane peu pour cinq
minutes et pour le groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame et
monsieur les rapporteurs monsieur le
ministre collègues nous aurions été
prêts à vous suivre sur la nécessité de
mettre en cohérence les forces
concourant à la sécurité publique
en effet l'absence de distinction claire
des rôles et des missions des uns et des
autres police nationale et gendarmerie
police municipale et enfin organismes
privés de sécurité a nourri depuis des
années la confusion une confusion qui a
grandement facilité le désengagement de
l'état de sa mission régalienne assurer
le droit de nos concitoyens à la
sécurité vous le savez les députés
communistes sont souvent élus de villes
ou de quartiers populaires qui sont
confrontés à de graves difficultés de
vie et nous nous battons pour que les
populations de ces territoires aient
accès au temps que les autres à la
sécurité la sécurité sociale bien sûr
celle d'un toit de droit et des services
publics
trop souvent négligée mais aussi le
droit de vivre en sécurité tout
simplement quel que soit son adresse
sans crainte de voir sa famille ou ses
proches ni insulter ni molestés ni privé
du peu dont il dit
pause nous on nous étions prêts à
traiter sérieusement de cette question
mais vous avez préféré faire du
marketing autour des drones et des
caméras au terme de nos débats loin de
répondre à la promesse de clarifier
distinguer le rôle des différentes
forces de sécurité cette proposition de
loi les superpose et désorganisent un
peu plus le service public
le risque est grand de voir s'accélérer
le transfert de responsabilités vers les
polices municipales mais aussi vers les
officines privées que votre loi ne
régule pas du tout
l'etat sera toujours moins le garant de
la sécurité sur le territoire de la
république une et indivisible
le résultat nous le connaissons d'
avance avec d'un côté une sécurité de
riches pour les riches et de l'autre une
sécurité de pauvres pour les pauvres
sur ce sujet comme sur tant d'autres
vous aviez promis une république en
marche et vous ne produisez qu'une
république en miettes vous fracturé le
pays
et comme votre seule matrice et comme
votre seule matrice et le libéralisme
économique
tout le reste est pour vous accessoires
même les libertés les plus fondamentales
et à l'image de l'article 24 qui n'est
d'aucune utilité pour protéger les
policiers de ce qu'ils peuvent subir et
qui est une question très sérieuse en
soi se marrent martic sera par contre
très efficace pour brider un peu plus la
liberté d'expression et la liberté de la
presse
chers collègues ce que nous savons des
graves événements qui se sont déroulés
cette nuit place de la république
nous le devons aux caméras des
journalistes et des citoyens présents
sur place et qui n'ont fort heureusement
pas été intimidé par vos intentions
législatives
leurs témoignages sont précieux il porte
un éclairage accablant sur les décisions
d'un préfet de police qui décidément une
fois de plus semble avoir fait le choix
de placer ses pas dans ceux ne sont plus
sinistres prédécesseur mesdames et
messieurs de la majorité et du
gouvernement
combien de temps pensez-vous
voir continuer de tenir ainsi le pays à
distance en l'observant de loin par
drones interposés
c'est une voie dangereuse sur laquelle
vous engager le pays
la sécurité de nos concitoyens méritent
- de manoeuvre est plus date républicain
oui nous avons besoin d'une grande loi
d'orientation pour remettre la police
sur ses deux jambes
celle de la répression et celle de la
prévention l'efficacité de la première
dépendant de l'efficience de la seconde
oui nous avons besoin d'une police basés
sur l'humain et moi plus sur l'humain et
moins sur les algorithmes et la
technologie et nous avons surtout besoin
de rétablir l'indispensable lien de
confiance qui s'est abîmé entre le
peuple et les forces de l'ordre
nous avons besoin d'un état qui protège
avec une police du peuple pour le peuple
et non une police d'état au service des
seuls intérêts du pouvoir en place
cette pente est fatale c'est pourquoi
nous voterons contre cette proposition
de loi et pensons nécessaire date
heureuse d'interroger sa
constitutionnalité par le moyen d'un
recours s'il devait elle devait être
adoptée
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur thomas rudigoz ce pour cinq
minutes pour le groupe la république en
marche
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des lois
madame tour au monsieur fauvergue
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues notre assemblée
s'apprêtent à voter un corpus de
dispositions qui sont le fruit d'une
mission parlementaire menée il ya deux
ans par nos collègues jean-michel
fauvergue et alice tour au visant à
parfaire ce qu'on appelle le continuum
de sécurité je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer
la qualité de votre travail mes chers
collègues je citerai quelques mesures
phares de cette proposition de loi
élargit cement du domaine d'intervention
des polices municipales avec de
nouvelles compétences de police
judiciaire la ville de paris qui pourra
se doter d'une police municipale partout
en france
la mutualisation des polices municipales
à l'échelon intercommunal sera possible
l'encadrement des activités de sécurité
privée et de la sous-traitance de cette
profession un nouveau cap pour l'accès
aux images de vidéo protection
la création d'un régime juridique pour
la captation d'image par moyens
aéroportés répandant ainsi à une demande
du conseil d'état et de la cnil et
dernier exemple de dispositions
l'interdiction de l'achat et de la vente
d'articles pyrotechniques réservé aux
professionnels ces mesures de
renforcement de la capacité
d'intervention de nos forces de police
sont nécessaires nécessaire face aux
nombreuses menaces que connaît notre
pays
la menace terroriste le grand banditisme
les trafics de stupéfiants
les violences violences faites aux
femmes et les diverses formes de
délinquance alors oui mes chers
collègues nous assumons de dire que nous
comptons sur les gendarmes sur les
policiers nationaux sur les policiers
municipaux pour protéger les français
qui dans leur très grande majorité
soutiennent leurs forces de sécurité
pourtant aujourd'hui personne ne peut
nier qu'il travaille dans des conditions
toujours plus difficile et que les
réseaux sociaux n'arrange rien
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé de
légiférer sur ce sujet l'article 24 a
suscité un important débat y compris au
sein de notre groupe
il vise dois je le rappeler à
sanctionner les personnes qui appellent
à la violence contre les policiers et
les gendarmes
les personnes qui appellent à la
violence contre nos forces de l'ordre en
relayant sur les réseaux sociaux des
images permettant de les identifier
soyons clair néanmoins c'est avec la
même détermination que notre groupe
dénonce les violences policières qui
sont inadmissibles dans notre démocratie
ainsi le rapport demandé à l'igpn par le
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur gérald
darmanin suite à l'évocation de
personnes migrantes place de la
république est indispensable ces images
sont choquantes comme l'a dit monsieur
le ministre et la lumière doit être
faite sur les circonstances de cette
évacuation de même s'il ya eu des
atteintes à la liberté à cette occasion
nous les condamnons avec la plus grande
fermeté et de sévères sanctions devront
être prises
l'article vague cats a créé l'émoi de
certains de nos concitoyens certains de
nos collègues ont pu exprimer leurs
inquiétudes
nous les respectons sensible à ces
préoccupations nous avons donc amender
cet article le gouvernement l'a amendé
suite à une demande du président du
groupe est républicain marche en
précisant qu'il s'applique est sans
préjudice du droit d'informer
c'est un équilibre que nous avons trouvé
entre le principe fondamental de la
liberté d'expression telle que définie
dans la loi de 1881 et le besoin de
protection de nos forces de l'ordre face
à des appels à la haine et à la violence
contre eux de plus en plus fréquents
par ailleurs comme l'a rappelé ma
collègue naïm amoutchou en séance
vendredi dernier nous avons précisé que
seules les atteintes manifestes
j'insiste sur le mot manifeste seraient
prises en considération ce qui signifie
que le juge ne statuera que sur des cas
évident et le reste sera mis de côté et
il n'y aura donc pas de sanction
la même expression a d'ailleurs été
introduit dans la loi contre la
manipulation de l'information et le
conseil constitutionnel a alors jugé que
l' équilibre était respecté grâce à ce
mot manifeste le conseil constitutionnel
qui sera directement saisi par le
premier ministre comme il l'a annoncé
lors des questions au gouvernement
à aucun moment mes chers collègues nous
n'avons créer un délit d'informer comme
je lai entendu ce matin de la bouche
d'un responsable politique sur une
matinale
cela s'appelle de la désinformation
comme quoi c'est un phénomène viral le
groupe la république en marche
revendiquent que les libertés publiques
dont celle d'informer ne seront pas
entravée par ce texte de loi la liberté
de la presse
est un des piliers de notre démocratie
que nous défendrons constamment avec
force et conviction le groupe la
république en marche votre à cette
proposition de loi
je vous remercie merci je relaie la
parole à monsieur eric diard pour le
groupe l'est républicain pour cinq
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame monsieur les rapporteurs chers
collègues la question de la sécurité est
particulièrement préoccupante dans notre
pays
plus encore et depuis les attentats que
nous avons subie le mois dernier cette
proposition a donc pu être redéposer et
retravailler avec le ministère de
l'intérieur afin de s'adapter aux
nouveaux enjeux et combler les failles
qui nous ont été révélés par l'actualité
son examen en commission des lois a
permis de poursuivre l'élaboration de ce
texte
nous avons notamment compléter l'article
23 ans permettant l'exclusion des
réductions de peines automatiques pour
les personnes coupables de violences sur
les agents de police municipale des
douanes et des personnels pénitentiaires
l'examen en commission a également
permis de soulever les problèmes posés
par la rédaction de l'article 24 de la
proposition de loi
cet article vise à protéger les forces
de l'ordre en pénalisant le fait de
diffuser par tout moyen des éléments
permettant de les identifier dans le but
intentionnelle de leur nuire cet article
on l'a vu a été rendre en titre
entièrement réécrit en séance afin de
prévenir les risques
d'inconstitutionnalité
mais cette réécriture ne permettra
probablement pas d'empêcher la censure
du texte en l'état par le conseil
constitutionnel
nous pensons à ce titre que le premier
ministre a eu raison d'annoncer la
future saisine du conseil afin de
dissiper tous les doutes au sujet de
cette proposition de loi
nous pensons également que l'erreur
principale de cet article et qu'ils
s'intègrent dans la loi de 1881 relative
à la liberté de la presse et non dans le
code pénal comme cela devait être le cas
l'objectif de cet article n'est pas de
musée
la presse mais bien d'empêcher la
diffusion d'éléments permettant
d'identifier des policiers dans le but
intentionnelle de leur nuire pour autant
il est essentiel que l'on puisse filmer
les forces de l'ordre c'est le cas et ça
le restera
puisqu'il n'est en aucun cas question
dans ce texte d' interdire cela je
m'interroge également sur la
constitutionnalité de l'article 22
relatifs aux caméras embarquées sur les
drones qui n'apporte pas assez de
garanties en matière de respect de la
droit privé notamment en ce qui concerne
les images aériennes des propriétés
privées
nous tenons cependant souligné les
avancées que permettent les articles 23
et 30 de cette proposition de loi
l'article 23 nous l'avions dit met
l'accent sur le respect de l'autorité
en empêchant les personnes coupables de
violences sur les forces de l'ordre et
sur les pompiers de bénéficier de
remises de peine automatiques
l'article 30 quant à lui permet un
meilleur contrôle de la vente de
dispositif pyrotechnique en assurant le
traçage de la vente des engins de
catégorie f2 et f3 il prévoit également
la sanction des vendeurs et des
acheteurs
si ces dispositifs sont vendus à des
personnes qui n'ont pas l'autorisation
les connaissances techniques leur
permettant de manipuler ces dispositif
pyrotechnique
l'objectif de cet article est clairement
de prévenir l'usagé détourné des engins
pyrotechniques et des mortiers
comme on le voit de plus en plus souvent
dans certains quartiers mais cheikh
mystère collègues
contrairement à d'autres le groupe l'est
républicain s'est inscrit dans une
démarche d'opposition responsable et
constructive
est ce ça cela du début jusqu'à la fin
de l'examen de ce texte
nous avons soulevé les points qui nous
semblent est incorrect tout en étant
force de proposition
car notre objectif est que le texte qui
sera adoptée soit le plus efficace
possible en matière de protection des
français
c'est ainsi que nous avons porté
l'interdiction d'exercer une profession
relatives à la sécurité privée
pour une durée de sept ans si des
manquements graves étaient constatés
nous avons pu également effectué et
faire adopter le criblage par le service
national des enquêtes administratives de
sécurité des personnes qui souhaitent
travailler au sein des fonctions
sensibles des gestionnaires
d'infrastructure des transports publics
ce qui est une avancée majeure en
matière de lutte contre la
radicalisation au sein des services
publics
mes chers collègues cette proposition de
loi manque certes d'ambition mais elle
va dans le bon sens surtout elle ne
s'attaque pas la réponse pénale de la
justice
il est impératif de travailler sur ce
problème très rapidement car même avec
une bonne loi si la réponse pénale n'est
pas à la hauteur
cette loi sera inapplicable et restera
lettre morte
certains points restent encore amélioré
et il appartient désormais au sénat et à
la commission mixte paritaire de
travailler dessus en attendant ces
dernières améliorations et compte tenu
des avancées apportées au cours des
débats les députés les républicains
voteront en faveur de cette proposition
de loi
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur le président patrick mignola
pour le mouvement démocrate est
démocrate apparenté
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la rapporteure c'est le
rapporteur madame la présidente chers
collègues c'est toi dit de sécurité
globale a pour objectif de définir un
continuum de sécurité et surtout son
application c'est à dire les femmes et
les hommes qu'il nous faut protéger
parmi les forces de l'ordre elle est
d'autant plus nécessaire que les
français soient attachés à la liberté
ils sont d'abord attachés à leur liberté
et ses biens en protégeant les forces de
l'ordre qui sont ceux qui protègent nos
de liberté que nous là servons mais ils
sont non seulement attachés à la liberté
en général mais ils sont aussi attachés
aux libertés publiques et s'agissant
d'un texte comme celui-là avec le très
gros travail que pendant deux ans vous
avez réalisé madame et monsieur le
rapporteur
nous devons nous interroger pour que
chaque changement en matière régaliennes
sa compagne d'encadrement pour veiller à
ce que la protection des forces de
l'ordre n'entraîne pas restrictions dans
des libertés publiques et c'est tout ce
travail que vous avez fait est que nous
avons fait ensemble est encore dans cet
hémicycle la semaine dernière qui nous a
permis d'avancer
point par point sur tous les sujets qui
permettent une meilleure protection des
français tout en garantissant que le
cadre démocratique républicain qui est
le nôtre perdure nous avons avancé et je
veux le saluer pour que ne soit pas
organisé législation par ordonnance sur
les modifications en matière de
vidéoprotection nous avons avancé sur la
question de la sous-traitance à des
agences de sécurité privées car
s'agissant de pouvoir régalien
il était nécessaire que ladite sous
traitance puisse être encadré je salue
le fait que monsieur le ministre ait
accepté de le faire
s'agissant des casiers judiciaires pour
qu'on ait db2 vierge lorsqu'on a des
agents de sécurité qui interviennent au
nom et pour le compte de l'état et je
salue
le travail qui a été réalisé dans
l'hémicycle pour que la représentation
nationale limite ladite sous traitance à
50%
nous avons travaillé aussi sur le port
d'armes en dehors des heures de service
pour que celui ci soit encadré puisque
dès lors qu'on pose une loi elle est
supérieure aux circulaires qui organise
les publics concernés et les conditions
dans lesquelles le port d'armes
peut être assumé je me salue aussi le
travail qui a été fait sur les caméras
embarquées pour l'heure définir un
régime juridique et ça a été le travail
dès le dit jacques et la forge la
définition de l'utilisation des rodéos
des drones dans les rodéos et c'était le
travail d'isabelle florennes
nous avons donc progresser pour mieux
protéger tout en protégeant les libertés
reste l'article 24
erwan balanant a bien défini ce qui nous
gênait dans ce lien entre
intentionnalité et faute qui sur le plan
juridique nous interrogeait les uns et
les autres et je veux saluer de ce point
de vue là
l'excellent travail que le l'expérience
et l'expertisé de laurence vichniesky
appuis apportés à la représentation
nationale avec les modifications qu'à la
demande du président qui est cette année
un premier ministre a bien voulu
apporter à cet article 24 aujourd'hui
nous nous trompons plus de cibles la
cible ce ne sont pas les journalistes
c'est pas la liberté de la presse ce
sont les harceleurs ce sont les hargneux
ce sont les accable ce sont ceux qui
vont livrer votre visage votre adresse
le nom de vos enfants leur école pour
qu'ensuite ils soient livrés à la
vindicte populaire et que s'organise un
trac hce la cible est désormais nous
avons cette garantie car aussi vrai que
l'intention ne peut pas caractérisé la
faute
la profession ne donne pas autorisation
de harcèlement et c'est ça que doit
prévoir cette loi c'est que cette
profession soient protégés et que nulle
part sur le territoire nos forces de
l'ordre puissent simplement parce qu'ils
sont des forces de l'ordre est attaqué
harcelés et mis en cause dans l'eure
étudiants et celui de leur famille car
car la question nous devons nous poser
dans cet objectif de tout changement en
matière hégélienne doit entraîner
encadrement en matière de protection des
libertés publiques
c'est hier soir dans les actes
intolérables qui ont été commis place de
la république
est ce que si nous votons cette loi les
journalistes pourront continuer à filmer
oui est ce qu'ils seront obligés de
demander des accréditations pour aller
filmer non est ce que le ministre pourra
les sanctionner si les enquêtes internes
qui sont aujourd'hui conduite voire
externe si elles sont demandées démontre
que des actes délictueux ont été commis
c'est le cas dans ces conditions parce
qu'au fond tout ça tout ça c'est des
discussions entre nous c'est des moyens
qui sont organisées alors parce que ces
garanties ont été apportées
et parce qu'au fond les démocrates sont
des républicains largement ils voteront
cette loi merci monsieur le président je
fais annoncé le scrutin la parole est à
monsieur hervé saulignac pour le groupe
socialiste apparentés pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre madame et monsieur
le rapporteur chers collègues
cette proposition de loi a suscité tout
à la fois colère émotions
incompréhension et je dois le dire bien
peu de sérénité y compris parfois chez
ceux qui la portent tout au long des
débats le groupe socialiste et
apparentés a tenté en vain de vous
ramener à la raison
y compris en vous demandant de retirer
ce texte à la suite des événements
graves survenus hier soir à paris nous
avons inlassablement défendu des
libertés publiques malmenées
nous l'avons fait cependant sans jamais
nous départir de la nécessaire
protection due à nos forces de l'homme
enfin nous avons rappelé combien il ne
suffisait pas de protéger ce qui nous
protège tant il est vrai que tous les
français aspirent à être protégée et
vous avez à l'évidence penser la
sécurité de certains aux dépens de celle
des autres
dès lors que c'est bien la liberté qui
est la première sécurité et non l
inverse
malheureusement monsieur le ministre
vous vous êtes retrouvé prisonnier des
promesses que vous avez fait le 2
novembre vous déclariez avoir fait la
promesse de ne plus pouvoir diffuser des
images de policiers et de gendarmes sur
les réseaux sociaux
bilan des courses vous ne tenez pas vos
promesses à l'endroit des forces de
l'ordre votre texte est inopérant dans
son article 24 et va produire du
contentieux à l'infini comment
pouvait-il en être autrement
vous avez vu monsieur le ministre dans
cette ppl l'occasion de vous tailler le
costume du patron dont on a toujours
besoin quand on s'installe place beauvau
et au final la marque que vous avez un
privé est un coup de tampon indélébile
sur le visage d'une république qui a
besoin qu'on la soigne et non qu'on la
maltraite légiférer utilement suppose
que l'on regarde en face la réalité
sociale de notre pays
les français ont peur peur d'un virus
peur du terrorisme peur du réchauffement
climatique
peur de perdre leur emploi peur pour
l'avenir de leurs enfants perdus
confinement j'en passe et des meilleurs
face à la peur nous pensons qu'il faut
apaiser créer de la confiance tracer des
perspectives positives
nous avons invité nous vous avons
invités à ne pas rajouter de la défiance
à la défiance
vous êtes resté sourd à nos appels sourd
car la peur est un état bienvenus
pour qui veulent instrumentaliser aux
fins d'asseoir son autorité c'est dans
une france sous tension que l'on peut
brandir des périls pour justifier le
renoncement à tel ou tel bout de liberté
ainsi les drones vont pouvoir voler à
peu près partout les armes seront plus
nombreuses dans l'espace public
les polices municipales renforcer les
sociétés privées de sécurité
mobilisables et les images des forces de
l'ordre exploitable avec une facilité
déconcertante
mais que s'est il passé dans ce pays
pour que l'on en vienne à connaître une
telle dérive autoritaire
faut-il que non seulement le peuple et
peur mais le gouvernement aussi pour
mettre à ce point nos libertés
fondamentales en question à cet égard
les tergiversations sur l'article 24 en
disent long vous posez un sujet que nul
ne conteste l'incitation à la haine qui
visent parfois nos forces de l'ordre et
qu'il faut réprimer sans indulgence le
code pénal est là pour ça vous apportez
une réponse délié du sujet en créant un
délit de presse et en punissant tous les
français dont vous malmener les libertés
l'intention manifeste de porter atteinte
reste une intention un projet un dessin
vous allez au devant de graves
contentieux vous générez surtout une
immense confusion tant du côté des
forces de l'ordre que du côté de nos
compatriotes vous placez gendarmes et
policiers dans une situation
inextricable
dès lors qu'ils devront apprécier
notamment sur des directs l'intention de
leur porter atteinte ou pas ces mêmes
policiers et gendarmes sont pour
beaucoup
exténué et moralement et physiquement
vous devez entendre leur lassitude et ne
pas bricoler des amendements de dernière
minute qui vont compliquer plus encore
le quotidien de ce que vous prétendez
protéger le déséquilibre de ce texte ces
français presque exclusivement l'image
comme un moyen de contrôle et non pas
comme un outil de transparence au
service de la vérité et de la démocratie
vous préférez les images qui observe les
citoyens à celle qui regarde le monde
cette proposition de loi serait bien peu
de choses si elle ne s'inscrivait pas
dans la lignée de textes nombreux qui
tousse rogne sur des libertés enseigne
anciens
qui font notre république monsieur le
ministre depuis 2015 se sont écoulés un
peu plus de 1800 jour la moitié de ses
1800 jours ont été vécues sous état
d'urgence
nous vous disons avec force combien nous
refusons la banalisation de cette
situation que vous contribuez à
installer les libertés ne menace pas la
lutte contre la pandémie
elle ne menace pas non plus la lutte
contre le terrorisme
les images ne sont pas des armes
pointées sur la sécurité publique
elles sont ce que l'on en fait nous ne
sommes pas tous élus pour légiférer en
permanence sur des renoncements des
interdits des modalités de surveillance
et des sanctions quand va-t-on se mettre
enfin à fabriquer du droit émancipateur
des libertés nouvelles des progrès pour
tous ce texte en est si loin vous nagez
dans un contre-courant dangereux c'est
unanimement que nous voterons contre ce
texte
merci chers collègues
chers collègues je vous demanderais
d'écouté en silence des orateurs si vous
voulez pour suivre des conversations
n'hésitez pas à sortir d'autant que la
demie jauge que nous nous sommes fixés
permet un grand nombre d'entre vous
allez poursuivre leur conversation
l'extérieur de l'hémicycle la parole à
monsieur dimitri houbron pour le groupe
agir ensemble
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la président de la commission des
lois mais dame madame monsieur le
rapporteur
j'aborderai d'abord les événements
d'hier soir qui ne peuvent être occultés
dans ce débat bien sûr la police doit
être protégé et respecté comme symbole
de l'autorité de l'état et détenteur du
monopole de la violence légitime mais
cette mission l'obligent à un
comportement exemplaire et la doctrine
du maintien de l'ordre de l'ordre public
doit évoluer et prendre en compte à la
fois le besoin de rigueur vis-à-vis de
ceux qui cassent et agressent vraiment
mais aussi la nécessaire mesure et
humanité face à ceux qui protestent et
s'exprime pacifiquement le groupe agir
ensemble bien sûr renouvelle une
nouvelle fois son soutien indéfectible à
la proposition de loi des rapporteurs
alice toro et jean michel potvin
cette loi sera l'un des grands marqueurs
de son quinquennat et nous contribuerons
en la votant à protéger à protéger ce
qui nous protège parce que rappelons le
chaque jour en moyenne 110 policiers
gendarmes et pompiers sont agressés et
ne rien faire aujourd'hui c'est là chez
celles et ceux qui risquent
quotidiennement leur vie pour nous le
groupe agir ensemble souscrit à
l'intégralité des mesures contenues dans
ce texte en séance le texte a été
enrichie émeutes ont notamment plusieurs
avancées nous saluons l'apport de nos
collègues du modem sur la clarification
de l'article 10 puisque est prévu une
incompatibilité d'activité parce que de
sécurité privée lorsqu'une personne est
titulaire d'un casier judiciaire c'est
une marque d'exemplarité indispensable
dans un autre registre je salut grâce à
deux amendements de mon collègue loïc
dombreval la prise en compte du respect
du bien-être animal dans la formation de
ceux qui travailleront avec les chiens
au sein de la police municipale et dans
le cadre de la sécurité privée la
rédaction retravaillée par le
gouvernement et les rapporteurs de
l'article 24 de cette proposition de loi
en étendant notamment sa protection aux
agents de police municipale nous
apparaît satisfaisante
la police municipale est également un
chaînon majeur
du continuum de sécurité des images
édifiantes et malveillantes ne doivent
pas pouvoir être jetés en pâture sur les
réseaux sociaux
enfin l'adoption de notre amendement de
groupe permettant aux gardes champêtres
d'avoir recours aux appareils
photographiques dans le cadre de la
lutte contre les atteintes aux
propriétés rurale et forestière est
évidemment une belle avancée nous notons
l'engagement du ministre de l'intérieur
quant aux divers décret à venir
permettant aux policiers municipaux
d'avoir accès notamment au fichier des
véhicules volés en lien avec leurs
compétences en matière routière mais
également et surtout au fichier des
personnes recherchées
chaque jour qui passe sans que cet accès
ne leur soient autorisés et du temps
perdu pour le travail de la police
nationale enfin je noterai la création
de la police municipale de paris qui est
un tournant historique et trop souvent
occultée dans ces débats je salue le
travail depuis plusieurs années de mon
collègue pierre yves bournazel élue à
paris qui a milité activement depuis des
années pour cette création c'est chose
faite aujourd'hui
enfin je tiens à dire que le groupe agir
ensemble et particulièrement attentifs
au respect de nos libertés et que accusé
les groupes et les députés qu'ils
voteraient ces propositions doit d'être
contre les libertés est une
contradiction puisque ça a été rappelée
protéger nos forces de l'ordre c'est
garantir à nos concitoyens d'être
protégé et ses propositions de loi nous
paraît totalement équilibrée dans sa
rédaction actuelle et notamment
l'article 24 pour permettre à la fois à
la presse de s'exprimer et les vidéos
d'hier soir témoigne que ce nouvel
article ne les empêchera pas de films et
de dénoncer ce qui leur paraît être
contraire aux lois de la république
l'article 24 bien simplement protéger
toutes celles et ceux qui risquent
quotidiennement leur vie je tiens à
rappeler le soutien du groupe agir
ensemble à cette proposition de loi et
aux rapporteurs
merci
la parole est un monsieur christophe
naegelen pour le groupe u10 indépendant
et pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la présente madame monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
ce texte de loi et est hautement
symbolique et nous allons différencier
le fond et la forme sur le fond
sur le fond il apporte énormément de
points positifs qui viendront complément
avoir une certaine pour nos policiers et
nos gendarmes compléter le continuum de
sécurité en effet nous allons pouvoir
expérimenter l'élargissement de leur
domaine d'exploitation sur la voie
publique afin qu'ils puissent constater
des infractions comme la vente à la
sauvette le défaut de permis de conduire
l'occupation abusif et d'autre il ya
aussi une vraie montée en puissance de
l'échelon intercommunal dans le domaine
de la sécurité
un amendement pour encourager la
mutualisation des services de police
municipale à travers des six lui un
amendement aussi qui va permettre au
point que les policiers municipaux
puissent quitter le territoire de leur
commune afin de conduire un individu en
ipm dont l'hôpital d'une commune et je
tiens à saluer particulièrement cet
amendement car il avait été porté par
jean christophe lagarde est nôtre et
notre groupe et nous allons tout
simplement pouvoir sécuriser la création
de brigades canines de police municipale
en les dotant d'un cadre juridique clair
point positif aussi concernant les
prérogatives des agents de sécurité
privés avec un encadrement renforcé la
création d'un observatoire national
mais dans ce texte il ya aussi certains
points il faut le reconnaître qu'ils
seraient améliorés dans la navette
parlementaire déjà pour les polices
municipales la nécessité de réduire ce
seuil de 20 policier municipal pour que
justement des communes ou des
intercommunalités plus petit puisse
avoir le droit de faire
cette expérimentation concernant les
agents de sécurité privée le fait de
supprimer la nécessité d'être habilités
pour effectuer des palpations de
sécurité n'était certainement pas
obligatoire il aurait fallu maintenir
cette cette habilitation l'article 24
l'article 24 nous en avons parlé
longuement dans cet hémicycle elle il ne
faut pas faire d'amalgamé avec ce qu'il
s'est passé hier soir on a trop entendu
trop entendu des personnes qui en ont
fait un amalgame la réalité des choses
c'est que même si la loi avait déjà été
voté les images que l'on a vu hier soir
nous aurions quand même pu les voir
et quand on prend l'article 21 et
l'article 24 ils servent non seulement à
protéger nos policiers c'est le premier
point mais ils servent aussi à protéger
les manifestants
car lorsque nous aurons accès à ces à
ces vidéos on pourra voir les policiers
les gendarmes qui ne font pas leur
travail de manière correcte et c'est une
infime minorité
il ne faut pas oublier que ce texte les
depuis de nombreuses années nos
policiers et nos gendarmes sont dans une
situation qui est extrêmement difficile
il est de notre devoir de les protéger
au mieux tout en étant dans une
situation complètement à transigeant
avec ceux qui le font de manière non
correctes le point qui pose le plus
problème serait l'article 22 sur les
drones et je pense qu'il n'aura
réellement besoin de la navette
parlementaire pour discuter de cet
article et notamment la problématique de
ne pas avoir exclu d'autres lieux que le
domicile est donc techniquement en
laissant en suspens beaucoup de
questions monsieur le ministre
madame monsieur le rapporteur cet
article 22 pose un vrai problème de
conscience
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui va amener
notre groupe qui votera majoritairement
dans une large majorité pour ce texte
mais avec néanmoins un certain nombre
qui vont s'abstenir
du fait de cet article du fait de cet
article 22 et il sera impérativement
nécessaire de retravailler dessus
bref nous sommes bien entendu favorables
au renforcement du rôle des policiers
municipaux tout en prévoyant une
articulation au mieux avec nos forces de
sécurité intérieure mais je parlais tout
à l'heure du fond et de la forme
sur la forme il aurait été intéressant
d'avoir des débats un peu plus ouvert
c'est à dire d'avoir des amendements
qu'ils soient un peu plus pris en
considération c'est ce qu'on peut c'est
ce qu'on peut regretter sur la forme de
ce texte ainsi que le fait que vous ne
vais pas me présenter au conseil d'état
en amont ce qui nous aurait sans doute
évité un certain nombre de problèmes
donc le groupe des indépendants votera
majoritairement pour le texte en
attendant la navette parlementaire et
différentes modifications
merci
bien je vais donc mettre aux voix la
proposition de loi le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 558
exprimé 492 majorité 247 pour 388 contre
104 la séance suspendue